dass ich q&d zu der neuesten recos gab
Knochenjob auf der Alp ich bin
romantisch der Job tatsächlich ist oder
wie hart es sind viel Kommentare danke
viel mal es war für deine beantworten
oder noch mit einem von denen zwei
älteren auf der Bella im Wallis das
erste Mal der fatmos wo fragt oder wo
schrieb das wäre vielleicht der schönste
hätte ja
[Musik]
du sprichst schon besah es ist ehrlich
gesagt nicht so einfach zum gleichzeitig
filmen und Fragen stellen und deiner mit
schaffen also es ist sogar unmöglich
wenn man das hätte dann hätte wir nur
über zwei Kamera macht und das ist jetzt
nicht wirklich die Idee
aber ja vielleicht ist eine Idee
selber darf und muss
auf jeden Fall notiert der Romulus Swiss
schrieb mich so keuchend den Berg hoch
eilen wenn daneben eine Seilbahn bereit
steht also ich glaube die seilbahnische
Winterbetrieb gemacht und nicht für den
Sommerbetrieb und ich glaube auch es
wäre nicht ganz praktisch sie für die
Älpler zum mit der Seilbahn rufen dann
muss man ja trotzdem total du ablaufen
zum Kühe wieder dahin also ich glaube
viel schneller während es mit der
Seilbahn nicht wirklich sie ähm und
selber im Kühlschrank
die meisten Fragen natürlich an sie zwei
Älpler der Raffi und der Bert Wert der
Ferien wird sie sind jetzt der Woche
gerade frisch vor der Auto
im Lande und mit dem Thema jetzt gerade
mal reden wir festhalten
[Musik]
spannende Reportage wie hat die Saison
verändert werden sie durch diese
Erfahrung etwas in der Zukunft sei es im
zivilen Leben als auch im Berufsalltag
anders machen ja
wieder zurückgeben im Alter Lappen
wieder zurückgebracht
aber wir werden sicher einiges mitnehmen
ich persönlich
geradezu
arbeitstechnisch
ganzen anderen
Sachen
die sind zu
[Musik]
90%, aber auch
Prioritäten also ich habe vorstellen
dass ich wenn ich zurück zum Job komme
mit großen Unternehmen wo die alle die
Prozess teilweise lang gönnt
ich glaube Chrissi hoffentlich gesunde
Geduld
zielstrebs schaffen sondern einen
Abschluss ja das hoffe ich das gar nicht
mehr
der erste Schritt ist jetzt noch derzeit
auf der anderen
us-jobs machen
wo man rufen sind eine Frau bevor im
Beruf
gefreut haben noch ein zuckert Abend
aber strenge leben
zwei Mal ich freue mich wirklich also
ich freue mich wirklich wieder zurück im
oktobersprünglich
gesagt
hoffentlich können bis mitten auf oder
aber freue mich definitiv zurück er hat
schwierig wird noch
dieses zurückkommen
ich würde noch der finanzielle Aspekt
interessieren
alles was über Alp läuft kann man auf
zahlpunk.ch
das sind relativ standardisierte Vertrag
auf tralisch ist es so der Sender also
dadurch
eingestellt sie sind ist das
jeden Tag schaffen
können
natürlich
nichts oder weniger
dafür Ferien genommen oder unbezahlten
Urlaub mit mehrere bei unbezahlten
Urlaub
Football fragt wie machen sie es mit
ihren Partnerinnen oder Partner falls
sie welche haben ja mehr Glück wir
wollen nicht
auf Dauer
mit Bus und Bahn und noch Velo also
ich regelmäßig fast jedes Wochenende
[Musik]
um 4 Uhr morgens melken das ist
wahrscheinlich ein einfache Frage also
12 Stunden melden und das muss relativ
präzise also
morgen am 7 und
Nachmittag am Fiffi das das funktioniert
nicht
jetzt erst war oder wenn wir morgen vier
Jahr gefangen haben das aufgestanden
sind die stallufe i gerichtete
12 Stunde
das heißt wir sind normalerweise
und auch
fertig
und wenn jetzt das noch
Interesse
ja und dann wird natürlich schnell äh
oben oben
im Bett bin und
in der Praxis zeigt sich das ist so eine
Beginn
Werk Beginn
noch größer
der beste Kompromiss ist ja Sonne fragt
wie geht es denn der Kuh mit dem
Hinkebein gut
wir haben die schon
[Musik]
erfolgreichen Tieren kommt der Tierarzt
drauf oder wie bringt man die in die
Klinik ja also
die Tierarzt ganz klar also wenn man
wirkliches Problem hat wo man nicht
hinterher so schnell lösen oder
irgendwas
[Musik]
seriöses Problem der lythischen Tierarzt
da und der Tierarzt
die sind
einmal so Bücher relativ schnell auf
Platz also mit normalerweise innerhalb
von einer Stunde
Tierarzt auf Platz gehabt
irgendwo oder machen sie das alles
alleine das habe ich nicht verstanden
[Musik]
Region aber die sind nicht
also im Alltag sind die nicht ohne hed
aber
gesehen ist gerade wenn es darum
gegangen ist
[Musik]
verständige jordanei informieren
dann ist der pure oder hätte
ein anderes geschickt der Vertraute
sauber gemacht ja und dennoch die Frage
zum Schluss von Michael werde zwar
deshalb für sie noch einem Sommer
am Ende fragen
[Musik]
was sicher vor allem damit du hättest
mir kann jedes Jahr zu machen
[Musik]
besondere Situation wieder
auftauchtiertisch würde überhaupt nicht
ausschließen aber Planet danke vielmals
erhol dich gut und schöne Ferien das ist
sie von der
Q&A danke vielmal Hände zur klagt wenn
er schon da sind
Account abonnieren und RAK geht's beim
nächsten Mal wieder tschüss